hi i'm michelle my pronouns are she her
and i'm a senior software engineer at
netflix
today i'm going to talk to you about
what i've been working on with my team
in content engineering
for everyone here and watching virtually
feel free to post any questions in the
slack channel or afterwards and i'll
answer as time permits
so one question i'm going to answer now
is that i have no power to renew or
green light your favorite show
if i did there would be a show called
cake with michelle
where i just eat cake and tell you how
much i'm enjoying it
it would be really boring for you but
like super fun for me
but what i can do is help artists and
creators make the netflix originals we
all know and love
so my team is called production
infrastructure engineering or pi which
is also awesome
is responsible for helping to make sure
that they can work every day all day and
not worry about the infrastructure
powering their work
so here's what we're going to learn
about today
what technology did we use
what was the problem we were solving
who were the users
how did we make netflix workstations
what did we learn
from making netflix workstations
and finally
what's next
so before i get into the problem and and
why we did this i always like to give
like a quick teaser trailer of all the
technology i'm going to touch on today
if you're unfamiliar with any of them
don't worry i'll be kind of defining as
i go like what they are and how we use
them and what they're good for and if
you're an expert at any of them please
stay because i've got a lot of questions
for you
so at the top there's go having a cup of
java
we use salt for configuration and
spinnaker for fleet management
images are made with packer
we use a lot of aws services but i
wanted to highlight ec2 as the actual
instances dynamodb for the data and sqs
to support our event driven
microservices architecture
those ec2 instances
come with nice ccv
which is one of the ways we actually
remote into the instances and the other
being territory
[Music]
so what was the problem
historically
artists had machines built for them at
their desks and only had access to the
data and applications that they needed
while they were in the office
this system allowed for fully on-prem
solutions that ended at the door
there are a few reasons why this is no
longer feasible
first was the vast shift to work from
home in 2020
we had actually already started this
project late in 2019
but it really accelerated our timeline
while people are sometimes
are beginning to come back into an
office in some regions
the work landscape has irrevocably
changed as you all know
so
the second reason which is actually our
initial project mandate because in 2019
we did not know everyone was going to be
working from home
is that netflix wants to make content at
an
unprecedented scale
so i've worked in entertainment almost
my entire career
and never on this many projects at once
there are simply not enough artists in a
single geographic region to support the
netflix scale of content
production need needs to meet artists
where they are instead of trying to
bring people all in one place
finally by taking down traditional
barriers to entry the industry and
netflix becomes more accessible to all
types of people
losing access to great talent because
they live a hundred miles from the
closest office or have mobility
restrictions is simply not acceptable
that's weird double you didn't get to
see the picture for a second
okay
so a question that comes up is why not
just ship a computer seems much easier
right
so the north star for netflix
workstations was to provide
infrastructure for artists to get a
one-click experience
from sitting down to working on a shot
but that can also be accomplished by
building a computer and sending it to
them
so why not do that instead
the answers are flexibility and security
production needs can change fast
new cameras and new software make it an
ever-evolving space
by creating cloud-based workstations
adding anything from new features to
security patches can be quickly
distributed to all the workstations or a
specific workstation
a user can switch from one operating
system to another
by just opening a new window and sitting
in a new computer
instead of waiting for a package to
arrive in the mail they can get a more
powerful gpu or larger storage
with a quick configuration change
workstations like many cloud-based
applications are not designed to be
permanent
artists are renting a workstation not
buying it
the downside to that is accounting for
other features that come with a single
desktop so something like
persistent user settings
when working on a desktop
user and software settings are just
sitting on the hard drive and wherever
the software puts them it doesn't matter
it's always saved with the cloud-based
solution
we had to be more methodical and save
crucial settings to persistent storage
associate that with a user and attach
the storage to all future workstations
so there's always a trade-off when
you're going from one to the other and
making sure you can at least meet those
table stakes of what people are used to
so asset security is critical
inside studios files
have traditionally been passed around
many different ways from ftp to email
every time a file gets moved it creates
that access point for interception
by having all the files on cloud storage
along with the virtual workstation
files don't have to pass through those
intermediate services
it allows for granular controls of a
file's life cycle and access since they
never leave that original storage they
were on
so
who are these netflix workstations for
when designing netflix workstations we
need to balance the needs of three
significant personas those are artists
technical directors and pipeline
engineers
as well as the many supporting teams
that made this happen such as storage
and networking and all those experts
so artists want to focus on their art
and not on technology
they are the main end users of a
workstation
they want to get what get to work
immediately and not wait for a computer
to boot up or
figure out what files they need to
download or anything like that
and artist workflows can vary wildly
depending on which step of a film or tv
production they're on
but kind of the basic needs of any
artist is the same
so i'm going to dig a little deeper into
these users and kind of give you more of
what they are
so
artists can have source files that
includes anything from
original film plates to reference images
to lidar scans they can be
anything huge amounts of data
the artists then use digital content
creation or dcc applications
to create new images
they could be final drawings or they
could be blueprints for a render for the
final frames
these new files then have to be shared
for review
and all of these steps would ideally be
completed on a netflix workstation which
includes other tools and plugins to
manage that whole pipeline and that
iteration such as task management and
shot reviews and all that
our other users are technical directors
they have both artistic and technical
knowledge
they work daily to improve that artist
experience
they need to be able to create scripts
and plugins for the artists and debug
all their problems
they also need to be able to do all the
same tasks as an artist
so all those dc applications to drop to
troubleshoot
any configuration help the artist get
their shot done
and it's the technical directors who
decide on the software
and ensure the artists are on the
correct configuration for the tasks
they're not on the wrong version of the
compositing software or the plugins
changing things the wrong color
so pipeline engineers focus exclusively
exclusively on creating the pipelines
and the workflows so i'm stepping out
further and further from the actual shot
work
their portfolios can include things like
file orchestration license management or
anything else
needed for the artist to complete their
work
they glue the pieces of the pipeline
together with
netflix workstations in the middle
and they make sure they can work as
efficiently and smoothly as possible
so my team started with a strong
emphasis
on building this complete
product
so the plan was always to move towards a
more self-service model and get the
technical directors and the artists more
involved in figuring out what they want
and building on the system
but the next step is actually build
a platform for the pipeline engineers to
build on top of so to provide that
curated artist experience and they can
have any customization they want and
just have a really strong
base infrastructure underneath
so how do we make them let's get to that
meat of that technology
so starting a new project can involve
making hundreds of technical decisions
both big and small
from picking a tool to naming variable
right
it can be overwhelming wondering if a
choice may now
will ruin an engineer's day a year from
now
well i'm here to tell you not to worry
about that because it definitely will
so have you ever worked on a legacy
project and thought wow the engineer
that wrote this was a genius and
everything they did makes perfect sense
of course not
the engineers before you were always the
worst
because they worked with the constraints
of what they knew then
not what you know now
so now that i've tried to completely
demoralize you
i want to give you a little hope
there are techniques we use to reduce
the bad choices
future engineers have to live with
if you've seen any of my other talks and
i'm sure you have because i'm really
famous
you'll remember i have a catchphrase
do less accomplish more
that is
focus on solving the problem and only
build what you absolutely have to what
is completely unique to your business
problem
so netflix values this culture of
freedom responsibility it's on our
culture memo and we're all about it yet
a commonly used
design philosophy is that of the paved
path
those are tools and practices that are
widely adopted and supported
engineers
can choose any tool or build any service
they want but it'll be much easier on
you if you use one of the paved paths
that matched my personal philosophy as
well and guided many of the team's
choices
of course sometimes you have to stretch
a metaphor super far and pave a new path
[Music]
you need to create or implement tools
that haven't been used before
that's when i put a premium on sell
community adoption as well as
reusability
if one service can solve multiple
problems it's more likely to get used
for the long term
so
in order to explain the technology
behind the large project i've broken
down netflix workstations into the
following like main components
the first is fleet management which is
making sure workstations are available
and tracking their individual life
cycles
the second component is configuration
management which makes sure the
workstations can be designed for any
artist's need and whether it's
installing an application or editing an
environment variable anything that can
be done
to a computer
so the next two are package and image
management which are kind of both sets
of configuration management
package management handles individual
packages like a single software or a
single environment variable while image
management handles that collection of
packages such as specificing all of
these packages are required for
compositing artists all these packages
are required for a previz artist
together they ensure configurations are
immutable with a clear history for
stability and observability
the fifth component is user access or
role-based access control are back
and how the right user gets the right
workstation and access to the right
files as you know is very important
finally
the remote display protocols are how the
user connects to and interacts with the
workstation remotely
so let's start with fleet management
so fleet management handles the life
cycle of a given workstation as well as
pools of workstations with identical
configurations
pools are similar to an auto scaling
group in aws but the control plane of
the netflix workstations handles all the
scaling manually
automatically instead of letting egs
asgs do it
the control plane is a collection of
java spring boot services
and we use spring boot because it allows
for easier
creation of java applications by kind of
abstracting away
some of the common tasks
java and spring also have a strong paved
path at netflix and many of our services
use it so it is an easy choice
so that control plane tracks the fleet
needs and alerts spinnaker to execute
them
so
spinnaker describes itself as an open
source
multi-cloud continuous delivery platform
that helps you release
software changes with high velocity and
confidence
it's a common tool for releasing and
maintaining services and it's on the
paved path again
spinnaker also controls the creation and
destruction of those workstation pools
so base configurations have a few few
variables that mix and match for each
use case
spinnaker uses pipelines as instructions
for creating those pools of workstations
which it calls clusters pipelines can be
accessed through an api and allow for
variables and expressions
we set up a variety of variables that
can be mixed and match for each use case
so for example artists could need a gpu
when doing graphic intensive work or
extra large storage to handle file
management
some artists need centos 7 to support
their software and others require
windows to kind of minimize the latency
and get
the
them working as fast as possible the
workstations
we go as close to the arts as possible
and support a growing list of regions
and availability zones
so the control plane directs spinnaker
pipelines to run whenever it needs a new
pool
or more workstations it connects
to the spinnaker clusters through the
their api to terminate a workstation
once the artist is done with it or
remove whole pools once that
configuration is stale and the technical
directors have decided we don't want to
use this one anymore
and in each workstation there's a go
line agent which provides a heartbeat
and other information about a
workstation back to the control plane
the agent lets the control plane know
the workstation is still up in the
correct state or needs attention and you
know which part of the lifecycle it's in
we chose golang for the agent because it
makes it really easy to cross build
executables for the different operating
systems which was a very early
requirement for this system
so configuration management starts at
the control plane but the details of
software installation and configuration
is handled by salt
we needed a system that could manage
hundreds to thousands of workstations
while being highly flexible and easy for
anyone to jump in and create new
configurations
and not just the platform team so this
is where salt comes in
the control plane uses salt to make
operating system agnostic
declarative statements
about how to configure a workstation it
uses a combination of yaml jinja and
python
it has a bunch of built-in modules or
you can build your own from installing a
package to file management to almost
anything
it also allows for logic statements to
handle situations such as mount this
storage in only this environment or only
run the script if this file doesn't
exist
so here's an example of a salt formula
this is the equivalent on centos of
running yum install this lighting
software
so
even though this example references
centos
the module is actually os agnostic and i
can use you know the package.install to
install on centos or windows and behind
the scenes it figures out is it yum is
it chocolaty how are we going to install
it
so
today we have over 100 different
packages
from workstations from all over the
place from the software to the registry
to the environment
variables so salt why did we select that
over configuration management tools such
as like ansible or terraform
because it was recently used in other
netflix projects and people given it
really high marks
and as well as being python based
python is kind of the standard language
for visual effects and animation tools
and it's used to build a lot of those
plugins and tools that the technical
directors and the pipeline engineers are
used to so it kind of creates those
bridges to them
and
working directly on the show so we want
to make it more available to people and
use tools that people are familiar with
so
initially we use salt formulas directly
allowing for fast change and super quick
deployment
everything was always the latest with no
ability to lock to a specific version
sounds great right
so
as the project grew this like wild west
of formulas became more challenging to
manage
any code that was deployed you couldn't
see
exactly what it was or when it was
changed or what was going on with it
we created this package management
system that wraps around the salt
formulas to kind of enforce some rules
and some control
the first is a template for all the
formulas
this makes it easier to avoid naming
conflicts and enforce rule such as
you know this formula is not going to
run successfully unless we know the
user's name or this formula is a
powershell script so only run this on
windows
the second is that all packages are
immutable to use a package on a
workstation it needs to be published to
a version
and if any changes are made it needs a
new version no matter how small the
change
this makes it a lot clearer what was run
it also allows for checks the publishing
stage such as syntax and testing so this
sounds like git it's pretty much that
you know we're using it to create
versions and control and making it like
a little harder to deploy but a lot
harder to know what's actually happening
okay
so i'm going to go in deep in the image
management the image management process
has gone through multiple iterations as
you learn more about the users and
observed how they actually use the
product
a workstation goes through three
configuration series
bake run and acquire
the different stage different iterations
will show how we move logic around
to better serve the user's needs and i
kind of like this case study to show
that like we made assumptions in the
beginning that we weren't right as we
worked on it and then those second
assumptions weren't right so we moved to
another one so i think it's fun to kind
of see the
the evolution of the product and not
just like say that we got it perfectly
right the first time because nobody does
okay so this chart shows at the bottom
those like three phases right bake run
and acquire
and then the actual logic is at the top
and they'll kind of be moving around
based on the iteration of the product
so all of the deployed workstations
start with an ami
an ami is an image used to launch
a workstation in aws
the bake stage is a process of turning a
series of instructions into an immutable
image if you feel familiar with docker
it's like a list of doctor instructions
that turns into a docker image
spinnaker then can use this image to
create that pool of workstations pretty
quickly
however the process of baking can take a
long time depending on
how much you're installing how big of
those software packages things like that
we wanted to ensure that while we were
in the alpha stage we could quickly
release new features
we didn't want to be held up by kind of
long weights while the ami rebate
so we only included minimal logic in the
bank stage
so just like the operating system and
the agent and that's all they pretty
much got
spinnaker creates the workstation during
that run stage the workstation now has
that agent and is marked as available in
the control plane for someone to acquire
there is no other configuration
happening in the first iteration of the
process at that run stage just
booted that booted that workstation up
and said now we're now we're ready to
use it
so the choir stage
is when a user says i want a workstation
right now i'm ready to get to work
and the first iteration most of the
software installation and all the user
configuration happening during the choir
stage
a kind of just-in-time approach
like making a sandwich once the order is
placed
there was no pre-ordering
before the user requested the
workstation this approach had maximum
flexibility but led to long wait times
so if someone will only get takeout at
restaurants where i can order a heads it
was like ready as soon as i get there
this was like totally unacceptable i
don't want to wait
and they need to do our artists
so
the long wait times led us to rethink
this and move the software configuration
and installation to the run stage so
this is the second iteration
this creates a pool of workstations that
have specific configurations instead of
just like just the os it's like this is
the compositing configuration this is
the previous configuration
however there are kind of two risks with
this method
the first risk was making many many
pools with like slight variations
it turned out not to be too much of an
issue
because in practice the usage patterns
of artists were not as like diverse as
initially thought like a lot of people
use the same configurations
this meant that while there were many
pools instead of the number didn't grow
to be unmanageable usually it'd be like
a group of people use one configuration
and then they want to do an update they
do a new configuration and then we can
kind of destroy the old old set of pools
so they're not around anymore
um
the second risk was inefficiency
so there were always idle workstations
ready to go for the artists which meant
they were just kind of sitting around
lonely unused racking up aws bills
this is an intentional decision in favor
of usability over efficiency which we
had before
of course this means
time for that third iteration
the third and current but probably not
the last iteration
is pushing the software insulation all
the way back to the base stage
this is like having a library of
blueprints instead of a bunch of empty
houses sitting around with no one living
in them
it's not it's less wasteful because
workstations can build from baked images
very quickly as they are needed
but don't forget we did not do this
initially because of those long bake
times you know we don't want people
waiting around 30 minutes every time
they had to change
however things have changed a little bit
since then the process has now come full
circle but instead of abandoning baking
we improve the process and develop
better tools that allows for concurrent
and easier bakes
integrating a lot with packard making a
lot easier to do
and do the bakes though the team also
kept those other options both those
iterations are all still possible as
backup because one of the many lessons
we learned from building a new project
is kind of hedge your bets right
so the tactile directors who handle the
configuration choices
are encouraged to give some time between
creating a new one and telling an artist
to get a workstation so it gives us that
that process gap instead of trying to
solve it with technology and runs other
problems so like hey
you know when you make new
configurations you can't have people use
it right away you need to give it a
little get a little warm up time so
maybe put that in your process a little
bit so
kind of moving moving the process around
so that's kind of with all projects
there are no perfect choices just a
bunch of trade-offs that kind of
maximize user experience
cost and technical efficiency
so the crucial part of any remote
workstation experience is connecting it
we currently use two different remote
display protocols
nice ecv and teradg
when deciding on which remote display
protocol to use the user must know how
they want to connect
this is not decided by the artist but
rather by which workflow they are using
generally it's the pipeline engineers
who originally got the artist team up
running decide on which workflow they
want to use
so teradici is a commercial solution
consisting of a
workstation agent software hardware
client and gateway components
nice ccv is an aws service provided on
any ec2 instance and allows for
browser-based connection and application
streaming
application streaming is pretty cool
because it allows for
a very streamlined performance
so artists instead of getting a full
desktop will just open their browser
window and get an application they can
open another browser window and get a
different application it's not like they
have desktops and desktops
it's just a cool workflow and people use
it different
ways so kind of for both these protocols
latency and peripheral connectivity were
kind of the vital features right for
example if an artist can't use a wacom
tablet or two giant monitors or five
giant monitors they won't be able to do
their work
and they won't want to work in a remote
workstation and will ask me to ship a
computer to them which i do not want to
do
okay and then initially all users
required and access netflix workstations
through a ui
key components needed to allow for
improved self-service are kind of in
that ui now this includes giving
technical directors the ability to
create configurations control access to
them with the role based access control
the ui is also where we use for
operators to visually check on the
health and usage of workstations such as
checking logs when a support request
comes in or making sure an artist is
using the correct workstation
there are dashboards to check on common
needs such as are we out of licenses or
did the auto scaler go haywire and make
a thousand workstations with among us
installed instead of compositing
software again that didn't happen
over the past year
we realized that
stakeholders were less interested in
kind of the opinionated product and more
interested in this robust customizable
platform
the current focus is shifting
all that stuff out of the ui to api
and pipeline engineer partners will be
light on to control that kind of
customized artist experience
the core strengths of netflix
workstations will be in a common
platform attributes such as reliability
observability and customizations
by focusing on those and kind of strong
partnerships they give me leverage for a
bigger impact kind of moving it all out
of the small circle and letting everyone
use it
so kind of just show the full workflow
in one pretty pink chart
put it all together
so
a workstation starts with baking the emi
is where the majority of the
configuration is happening
then spinnaker handles the fleet
management by turning that ami into a
pool of workstations
after that the agent starts up and makes
the workstation available for
acquisition
finally once a user requests a
workstation they connect to it with the
remote display provider
and when they're all done with it the
workstation gets terminated and the
cycle starts all over again with a brand
new workstation
the system is designed for the artists
and everyone who supports them
artists can get onboarded no matter
their geographic location to accommodate
dynamic production schedules they can
get any workstation they need with a
configuration change instead of having
to wait for a new one to arrive in the
mail
and technical technical directors can
quickly modify and control
configurations
to maintain stability while trying out
new tools
and finally pipeline engineers can build
on top of the platform to create a
different experience to a different
specific workflow
so what did we learn
everything was new when this project
started it was new roles
new teams an empty repository we kind of
made the best choices with the
information we had
then pivoted when real world users
showed us a different way
here's some of what we learned about
designing artist-driven technology
so nothing can be taken for granted when
making a significant leap in technology
the new technology of cloud-based
workstations must at the very least
match the old experience of dedicated
on-prem workstations
or the user won't use it
for example users rely on their software
settings to remain in place from one
workday to the next but it's not a given
on cloud-based workstation
therefore it's essential to learn all
the aspects of a user's workflow so
nothing is missing when they get to
using it
we focus first on technical flexibility
instead of the artist experience but
artists need custom workflows not
standard solutions
by initially building the entire product
we were painted into this little corner
we were on the hook for making
everything but unable to lower that
needed customization
instead we're pivoting to that platform
to build a strong core and allow for
partner customization empowering others
to develop with you gives your team more
leverage than they could accomplish as
individuals
the more this makes it easier for others
to contribute the better adoption and
the better iteration
engineers need to help each other
additionally the artists require
engineers to move fast but
in this case we can't break things a
seemingly impossible mandate but one in
which to inspire
it isn't fun when someone's first
experience with a product isn't
delightful
observability and testing can seem like
things that can be cut when those
timelines compress and suddenly
everyone's working from home
in three months instead of the like
years you thought you had to build this
product
but they can come
come back and haunt you like super fast
we've committed to improving this area
and such as adding automated testing
clear clear failure modes things like
that
and finally we need to address one thing
at a time from the micro to the macro
level from small tickets and small pull
requests small releases
you know every time we tried to abstract
too early and build for every use case
it never got right so doing one thing
validating and iterating is how we're
going to know what systems robust and
kind of getting on the right track
so
like the christmas prince universe
crossovers and spin-offs make things
more fun
netflix workstations are one part of a
technology ecosystem designed to help
content creators make future films and
television on an unprecedented scale
this ecosystem consists of many other
teams that help use our infrastructure
in new and exciting ways
we'll be collaborating to plug
workstations into more and more
workflows so talent worldwide
can be part of making diverse content
okay as part of that here's my
obligatory plug to be a part of the team
if i got it just got you excited about
all the possibilities of building new
technology for a new studio please reach
out
i'm happy to answer questions now looks
like i have a huge amount of five
minutes
and or throughout the conference i have
an ama actually right after this if you
want to join me on the midway it's right
next to where we had lunch
or feel free to reach out on linkedin
just make sure to send a message or i'll
think you're a robot
and thank you for listening thank you to
all my stunning colleagues without whom
there'd be no netflix workstations
so i'll repeat the question it was about
what happens when artists are working
somewhere where they don't have good
internet and can't work on your cloud
workstation
we've done a lot of tests in this
and it and it's very difficult but it's
about um that's where we try to get to
close as them as possible and kind of
get that latency down
and if it's
it's a lot of that is on that both the
regions and the remote display protocol
will you know cache things they'll bring
them out we'll find ways of getting to
it but that's definitely somewhere we
can improve
and it's also why you know we
build one region at a time we you know
build this one region see how the people
there are using it what do we get out of
it and then move one to one um i have
gotten this question before like what if
you want to work outside it's like well
you can't light an image
in the sunlight so i at least can beat
the like people won't be working in the
park
so at least working in a building
so at least get that for free
ah so far so good i mean we definitely i
like like i said this is a brand new
project it's not perfect there's plenty
of things to improve
but
you know
you know we we get stuff all the time
when trying to do it but yeah video
editing can happen on a cloud
workstation
you know
people are working on these super high
res images and doing all sorts of really
cool stuff with them and they're able to
do it on their cloud workstation
yeah so the question was do i have the
same problems as game streaming where
you're trying to collate the data to the
region the person is working in uh yes i
mean that's part of that slowing down
the latency like anything that can be as
close as possible to where they're at um
and and building that stuff up so yes
that's definitely something you we have
to address as we build region after
region and kind of spread around
yeah so actually the most important
thing for us was to start with how do we
match their previous experience like we
don't want it to be worse because then
they're never going to use it right so
after we get to that point of like you
know solving all those back end
difficult challenges like the latency
and making sure their wake-up tablet
works and making sure it comes up
quickly and the files are all there and
it doesn't just crash in the middle of
nowhere and they don't using so all
those like kind of table stakes that's
what comes first for us right and make
sure that's working and then you can get
to the you can kind of let your
imagination run wild that's why i like
talking about nice dcvs like application
streaming because that's like a totally
different workflow than just using a
desktop with a bunch of other stuff on
it so i think it'll change things as
people get used to it um
and also that whole thing of like
changing one thing at a time right we
don't want to try to change
the entire workflow at once because
there's that mental load of like
learning new ways to do things so first
we just want to make sure they can do
their exact work wherever they're at and
then it's like well maybe there's other
more efficiencies we get out of
doing this that we can add in to add
into the workday
yeah so the question was about
collaboration are people using the same
workstation at the same time right now
no but that is something we explored uh
specifically for reviews right like oh
i'm working on this supervisor can you
remote in and look at what i'm working
on right so that's that's one of those
things that we're looking into but it's
not it wasn't that critical kind of mvp
path but it'll be really cool when it
does that you know you run into all
those like is it going to slow it down
what if they're in another region what
if you know we don't want to wha
what is the
identity story for that so
it kind of like opens a can of worms but
it also opens for a lot of really cool
collaboration so you gotta sell for both
all right i am out of time
but
thank you
um i'll be just heading over to the
midway to do an ama about we can talk
about this we can talk about life at
netflix jobs what the team is like happy
to answer any questions
thanks everyone
[Music]
you